on this friday night the fight against
kova 19 gets another shot
in the arm health canada approves oxford
astrazeneca's vaccine
this is a great news plus a reality
check on whether delaying the second
dose
actually saves lives america's air
strikes on iran-backed militias
the revenge for a deadly rocket attack
and cracking the code
we just thought that it was a game the
hidden puzzle
on perseverance
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us the vaccination campaign
in this country is picking up steam
canada has given the green light to the
oxford astrazeneca shot
it's the third vaccine approved for use
here and the first shipments are
expected
within days canada has also partnered
with india's serum institute
to get 2 million doses of the
astrazeneca kova shield vaccine
as soon as possible half a million are
reported to be arriving on wednesday
the doses are in addition to the 20
million already secured
with astrazeneca so there are a lot of
numbers out there
here's the bottom line with pfizer
moderna
and now astrazeneca canada will get
to more than six and a half million
doses
by the end of march michael couture
explains what we know about the
astrazeneca vaccine
and how it will impact canada's
vaccination rollout
the next several weeks to months is
going to be very very good in terms of
the vaccination front
from doctors on the front lines to
politicians in the halls of power
the reaction to the approval of a third
covid19 vaccine for use in canada
was unanimous i think it's the best news
we've heard in a real long time and
we all the the two questions we need
answered is when we're getting it
and how much we're getting canada has a
contract for 22 million doses of the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine
some of which are part of a deal with
the serum institute of
india and the first shipment will be
significant
500 000 doses will be delivered
to canada in the coming days the pfizer
bayern tech and modernist shots are
mrna vaccines but oxford astrazenecas
is a more conventional viral vector
vaccine
which can be stored at temperatures
between two and eight degrees celsius
meaning it can travel more easily and be
administered in your doctor's office or
a pharmacy
but there's one stat some are stuck on
this vaccine
has a 62 percent efficacy rate much
lower than the two already approved in
canada
dr supriya sharma says you need to dig a
little deeper into the science to
understand
what this all means the number of cases
of people that died from covid19
that got vaccine was zero
the number of people that were
hospitalized because they're
cova 19 disease was so severe
was zero doctors point out depending on
the year the seasonal flu shot is only
about
60 percent effective the point of the
covit 19 vaccine isn't just to prevent
you from getting covid19
it's to reduce the effects of the virus
it's a huge public health wind
transforming a severe illness into
something that's very mild and easily
dealt with by immune by your immune
system and that could come even quicker
with the approval of the johnson and
johnson
single dose vaccine health canada
officials say the review of that vaccine
is in the final stages but they don't
expect any announcement
in the next few days robin mike licature
in ottawa thanks mike
more canadians are being vaccinated but
case numbers are on the rise in three of
canada's
biggest provinces daily case counts in
ontario alberta and bc have
increased between 8 and 14 percent over
last week
the same three provinces are reporting
the highest number of infections
involving those
concerning variants
given the much narrower margin of error
with these variants
controlling the epidemic would be much
more difficult
that rise in variant cases is putting
more pressure on protecting vulnerable
canadians
some in the medical community are
calling for a new rollout strategy that
considers
delaying the second dose heather york's
west looks at the risks
and possible rewards at this vaccination
clinic in laval quebec
the race to protect as many vulnerable
seniors as possible
is on it's currently open to anyone 85
or older 88 year old bernard beaupre
says his kids made him come he said you
have to get vaccinated
we don't want to lose you quebec is
handling vaccine rollout differently
than other canadian provinces
along with new brunswick quebec has
decided to get more
first doses into people's arms by
delaying a second dose by as much as 90
days
when you're in a vaccine limited setting
as we are in canada
at the moment and will be for the next
few months
we can you know effectively vaccinate
twice as many people
it's a strategy that so far appears to
be paying off in the uk
britain became the first country in the
world to approve a 12-week interval
between doses
not only does more than a quarter of its
population now have at least
one dose spacing the second dose at
least with the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
appears to improve the vaccine's
efficacy as well
they've really released some preliminary
data showing that
they they have a 12-week interval
between doses and that seems to be
more protective than the initial
recommended time between doses which i
believe was six weeks there is also
evidence that a single dose of either
the pfizer biontec
or moderna vaccine provides good
protection too
in healthcare workers we could see a
protection in the range of 80 percent
that started about 14 days after being
immunized whereas for long-term care
facility residents it took a little
longer about three weeks before
this protection kicked in there are
risks to extending the interval between
doses the science on this is essentially
being done
in real time but with the spread of
variant cases increasing the threat of a
canadian third wave
missing the chance to get more people
vaccinated sooner
carries a risk as well heather urex west
global news
calgary the ceo of canada's largest
pension fund has resigned and is taking
heat
over a trip outside the country mark
machin went to the united arab
emirates for personal reasons despite an
advisory against
non-essential travel meijin also
arranged to get the kova 19 vaccine
while there global news has learned the
defense minister was not aware of any
allegations or investigation
before admiral art mcdonald was
appointed chief of the defense staff
a spokesperson for harjit sajjan says he
became aware of the allegations
a number of weeks after the change of
command mcdonald's stepped aside this
week pending an investigation with no
official explanation
just last month he took over from
general jonathan vance who's accused of
inappropriate behavior with two female
subordinates
today conservative leader aaron o'toole
called for an independent investigation
into the military's handling of sexual
misconduct within its ranks
as david aiken reports the prime
minister took some tough questions
on the matter today the dual
investigations of the conduct of
canada's highest ranking military
officers
has rocked the canadian forces but prime
minister justin trudeau was reluctant to
say much
about those probes i won't be commenting
specifically on this
this process at this time other than to
say that the
following of all the steps in this to
make sure that
everyone has a chance to be heard and
that
people understand how seriously we take
all these concerns the opposition leader
aaron o'toole who
spent nearly a decade in uniform as an
air force officer
sees a broader issue he wants a
system-wide
independent external investigation and
a freeze on promotions and pay bumps
for all generals admirals and other
senior flag officers
until that investigation is done we
cannot allow
our daughters our sisters and our
mothers to work
in an unsafe environment no one
should be subjected to sexual harassment
when they show up to serve their country
meanwhile experts told the house of
commons defense committee friday that
those in uniform including the acting
chief of the defense staff lieutenant
general wayne eyre
cannot wait for investigations to run
their course
people need leadership in times of
crisis
general heirs right now so this is
obviously needed from the pm and
defense minister too but here on forces
members will look to their service
commanders and cds to set the tone
david akin global news ottawa
in a statement today lieutenant general
wayne ayers says we must strive to
ensure we look after our people
all of them and ensure we are an
institution in which canadians can see
themselves
how we do things is as important as what
we do
a newly released u.s intelligence report
has confirmed
saudi crown prince mohammed bin salman
approved an operation to capture or kill
journalist jamal khashoggi the report
says the assessment was based on the
crown prince's control of
decision-making in the kingdom
the direct involvement of a key advisor
and members of his protective detail
khashoggi was an outspoken critic of the
saudi regime
in 2018 he was tortured killed and
dismembered inside the saudi consulate
in istanbul the u.s has carried out an
airstrike targeting iran-backed militias
in syria
it's the first military action
undertaken by the biden administration
the pentagon says it was retaliation for
recent attacks on u.s
interests in iraq as jennifer johnson
reports the message behind this strike
may be more powerful than the attack
itself
in his first known show of force as
america's commander-in-chief
u.s president joe biden ordered
airstrikes on buildings used by iranian
back militias in eastern syria
the action was retaliation for the
malicious strikes in iraq last week
that wounded a u.s military member and
killed an american civilian contractor
president biden ignored reporters
questions about the airstrikes
as he left the white house for texas but
the pentagon says the president's
message was clear
the united states will act to protect
american and coalition personnel and our
security interests in the region
the airstrikes in syria targeted the
guardians of blood brigade
which took responsibility for the attack
that killed and wounded the americans in
iraq
the pentagon says nine of their
facilities were destroyed
we know what we did
and we're confident that that target was
being used
by the same shia militia that
that conducted the strikes iran's
leaders deny any links to the group
but the back and forth military strikes
could complicate the biden
administration's efforts
to renegotiate a nuclear deal with iran
former president donald trump rescinded
the previous agreement
president biden has pledged to try and
keep a tighter reign on iran
jennifer johnson global news washington
a journey out of north korea took 36
hours and that last lake
was likely the hardest
[Music]
employees of russia's embassy in
pyongyang and their families
used a hand cart to push their way
across the bridge that separates russia
and north korea they got to the border
by train but had to improvise to cover
the last kilometer of their journey back
home
the rail link between the two countries
is closed because of the pandemic
on the hunt for the perfect spy coming
up the help wanted ad from canada's spy
agency
raising eyebrows
spy agency inadvertently launched a
recruitment campaign that seeks
a double agent on twitter thesis used
this quote from john le carey's 1986
novel
a perfect spy but the book is about a
double agent who betrayed
his country cesa says the tweet was
meant to be a tribute to the late
british author
and people should only apply to protect
their country and keep their fellow
canadians
safe preliminary findings suggest voter
turnout in newfoundland and labrador
could hit a record low
the recent outbreak of cases certainly
threw the province's general election
out of whack and as ross lord reports
there are growing questions about how
the premier is balancing his leadership
during a pandemic
while being a political candidate in
newfoundland and labrador it seems
everything is a test
from ramped up covet 19 swabbing to an
evaluation of premier andrew fury
polls show fury's big lead in the
election campaign has shrunk since the
outbreak started
fury rarely makes himself available to
the media outside of regular coveted
briefings
where reporters are told not to ask any
political questions
this political analyst suggests by
appearing at the briefings
fury risks being seen as using them to
bolster his campaign
if he's going to be there it should be
crystal clear why the premier is
necessary there
he hasn't made that clear in these
briefings the two previous provinces to
hold pandemic elections
saskatchewan and british columbia kept
politicians away from covet briefings
it would not be appropriate for him to
be on the campaign and have the
opportunity to speak publicly twice a
week
but he will very much be involved in
ensuring
the ongoing management of the the crisis
but fury insists
he's only there to provide reassurance
well you know i think it's important
that the the people of providence
realize that they're still a premier and
there's still a cabinet in place
fury says he gives no input to the
province's chief medical examiner
on imposing pandemic restrictions
the province's election has already been
muddled the outbreak forced planners to
delay voting
and switch to mail-in ballots there are
fears of a record low turnout
with some residents admitting they won't
vote out of frustration
pc leader chess crosby says he's
collecting information
that could be used to launch a legal
challenge of the makeshift plan
there are already suggestions the
province might need a do-over
it's possible we don't want to wait
around for the courts
for however long it'll take to tell us
so it's possible we can figure this out
on our own
that we we might actually just need to
have another election anyway
those who are voting have two weeks
remaining to get their ballots in the
mail
ross lord global news the standing
committee on canadian heritage held a
virtual meeting to discuss
bill c-10 also known as the bill to
modernize the broadcasting act
several key players in the industry
including chorus entertainment which
owns global news
took part bill c-10 is not perfect but
it gets one big thing right it will
finally bring foreign digital
broadcasters into the regulatory fold
and start to level the playing field for
canadian media
and for us this is reason enough to
support it
the long-anticipated legislation was
introduced last november
it's the first in a three-pronged
government approach to regulate online
streaming services
and their influence in canada
conspiracy warning still ahead the
infodemic
emerging from the pandemic
what's historic about the pandemic we
are in now is the use of technology and
social media on a massive scale to keep
the public informed
but those platforms are also being used
to spread disinformation
and conspiracies about the virus jeff
semple has more on how canadians can
break the chain
of misinformation dr joy hatley
is fighting covet 19 on two fronts
caring for patients at this ontario
hospital
while also battling a parallel pandemic
why do you lie on your news
of disinformation claims kovid 19 is a
hoax
it's now affecting my ability to care
for my patients because
there's a trust factor and there's an
uncertainty on their part
it's a topic of conversation at most
dinner tables
including her own hatley started hearing
covet conspiracies
from members of her own family her
father
sharing videos like this one it's about
creating fear
so that people will not ask any
questions with widely debunked claims
that the kovit 19 test
is fake and that bill gates is secretly
inserting trackable microchips into the
vaccines
so i went back to my dad and i said dad
i'm sorry to worry about you
like that's just nuts because people are
afraid this expert in conspiracies
says that the pandemic has produced a
perfect storm of fear
frustration and isolation with more time
spent online it's not people who are
uneducated or
people who are you know on the lowest
end of the social economic
tiers it's people everywhere that are
being
brought into this the covid conspiracy
super spreaders
include an eclectic mix of anti-vaxxers
as well as anti-immigrant and far-right
hate groups
and much of their disinformation is now
focused on vaccines
we've picked up the chinese basically
spreading
falsehoods about western vaccines that
they can't be trusted
i think the wider concern is that if
these groups continue
what impact will that have on canadians
wanting to get vaccinated
dr hatley says that's what worries her
the most
and you think this can't happen in
canada how does this happen
in our country conspiracy theories
thought to exist on the fringes
are reaching into the homes of ordinary
canadians
threatening to undermine the pandemic
response
jeff semple global news toronto
and be sure to tune in to jeff's story
on the new reality he speaks to a young
woman whose mother became a conspiracy
theorist
during the pandemic that's tomorrow at 7
pm right here on global
up next decoding in different dimensions
how earthlings solve the puzzle
on mars
when nasa successfully landed
perseverance on mars
the space agency hinted there was a
secret message hidden inside the rover's
red and white parachute
that sent internet sloughs into a
tailspin to try
to solve it well our eric sorensen
caught up with the college student from
france
who cracked the code he chilled up
the images were extraordinary tango
delta the rockets
the rover the resolution of pictures
from the red planet
and there was the parachute and
something most people missed
the pattern it's not symmetrical but
neither is it random seems nasa had a
little fun with that
sometimes we leave messages in our work
for others to find for that purpose
so we invite you all to give it a shot
and show your work that's all the
inspiration maxson's abella needed
i'm a big fan of space exploration the
computer whiz called up his
software engineer dad to try to crack
the message
i saw it as a tip that we had to look
for something
and we proceeded to try and decode
that so what coded message would
earthlings take to another planet
space the final frontier
may the force be with you to infinity
and beyond endless possibilities
for maxons the real meaning was embedded
in that design on the parachute
the orangey red colors and the whites
could be translated to a binary code of
ones and zeros
basic computer translation and the right
counting scheme produced specific
letters of the alphabet
and in a clockwise pattern revealed this
dare
mighty things that and the gps location
of the jet propulsion laboratory in
california
cute we found numbers
that corresponded to alphabetical
positions
max did indeed show his work online
we found their mighty things that way it
was very nice
it's awesome it's also the motto of the
jpl team
you can see the phrase all around nasa
the message hiding in plain sight when
chen
spoke and we still get to dare mighty
things
together it's from a speech by u.s
president teddy roosevelt long ago
to dare mighty things to win glorious
triumphs even though checkered by
failure and that is the essence of space
exploration
push the limits fail sometimes and when
successful
catch on confirmed celebrate safely
on the surface of mars taking one more
step forward in scientific discovery
maxons abella says he feels a part of
the team now
and dares to hope he has taken a small
step toward the career he wants in space
technology
eric sorensen global news toronto
that's the best story of the day and
that is global national for this friday
night i'm robin gill
here's a riddle to start the weekend why
did the chicken hit the slopes
i'm sweating with a chicken oh my
goodness
because this four-year-old wanted to
take her pet named
chicky boo on a ride a saskatchewan
farmer captured her daughter's
foul play and it's now a viral sensation
and it just goes to show chickens can be
brave
thank you for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a great night
you